Alors que la France traverse une période d'élections présidentielles ultra-sensible
Alors que le contexte politique est explosif
Alors que tous les Français ont les yeux rivés sur le destin de leur pays...
Norman sort une vidéo engagée extrêmement polémique qui va tout changer...
Euh non c'est une vidéo sur les serveurs, dans les cafés et tout
Et alors ?
Vous allez me juger c'est ça ?
"Eh J'suis pas venue ici pour souffrir ok ?"
Les serveurs dans les restaurants ou les cafés je les aime bien mais parfois
sans s'en rendre compte ils font des actions pas très gentilles, comme par exemple...
Quand le serveur te place sur cette table bien bancale où tu dois mettre un petite cale en papier de merde pour la stabiliser
Ou sur cette table que personne veut, juste devant les toilettes
Toi et moi ça fait maintenant 6 mois et j'aimerais qu'on se fiance
oh putaain hé j'ai laché une merde  la dedaiins
j'ai pas craqué une allumette ça a explosé hé
Quand il te donne cette corbeille de pain bien bourrative
qui fait que t'as plus faim quand le plat arrive
L'addition s'il vous plait !
Quand t'as attendu une heure l'addition mais qu'il vient sans machine à cartes
bah du coup tu peux repartir
quand t’essaies de l’appeler mais que tu as 0 charisme
"S'il vous plait, s'il vous plait!
Madame?
S'IL VOUS PLAIT!
Est-ce qu'on peut vous donner du chiffre d'affaires s'il vous plait?
Ou encore quand il vient remplir ton verre, pile au moment où tu racontes un truc bien intime
elle s'est approchée de moi
elle a ouvert son chemisier
et c'est la que j'ai saisit...
Euuh...j'ai euuuuh...
je te raconte après
Alors moi j'ai absolument rien contre les serveurs,
mais je déteste quand ils veulent absolument te faire consommer.
Et puis de l'eau s'il vous plait.
Très bien, une petite ou une grande bouteille monsieur ?
Non, de l'eau normale
Ok une "Vittel" c'est parti
Non non non une carafe d'eau quoi, tout simplement.
Une carafe d'eau "Vittel" c'est parti
Non non, de l'eau gratuite du robinet qui pue les toilettes !
Voila c'est ça qu je veux, tout simplement
Pardon, excusez-moi.
Pétillante ou plate ?
Ou alors les serveurs qui font
Et le gigot, s'il vous plait
Très bon choix
C'est vraiment une phrase commerciale
C'est vraiment une phrase commercial
On sait tous que le mec fera jamais
Et le gigot s'il vous plaît
Vous êtes sûr ?
Moi perso je le trouve vraiment dégueulasse.
J'trouve que c'est le moins bon plat de la carte
J'sais qu'il y a, un restaurant, en tout cas, en face qui le fait plutôt bien
Après c'est un choix
Bon, et puis, évidemment comme tout le monde
J'aime pas, non plus, les serveurs désagréables
Dépêche-toi !
le plat du jour c'est quoi?
Le plat du jour c'est le plat du jour! Tu sais lire? C'est écrit là !
Plat du jour!
Et du coup le fromage, euuh...
Ben le fromage c'est fromage, fils de pute !
Madame, tu prends quoi?
Non, moi ça ira merci.
Ah tu consommes pas!? Ben tu t'casses !
Alors? On t'prendras une escalope, comme tout le monde !
Comme un bon gros radin, tu prendras de l'eau du robinet j'imagine?
Oui, voilà, va te faire enculer !
J'reviens dans 1h !
Merci...
Quoique...
En même temps, j'aime pas non plus le serveur trop présent
Celui qui veut être poli, mais qui en fait devient un peu chiant
Tout se passe bien?
Oui, merci !
Vous avez besoin d'autre chose?
Non, merci.
Vous êtes sûrs que tout va bien?
Oui, écoutez, tout va bien
ça peut pas aller mieux !
Limite à la fin, le mec il est comme ça :
Et le gouvernement ne fait absolument rien, quoi !
C'est abusé !
Excuse-moi, je peux avoir de la moutarde s'te plait?
Oui, bien sur !
Serveur!
Ils sont hyper longs, hein !
Parmi les serveurs, il y en a toujours un qui fait genre il a une mémoire de surdoué
en voulant retenir toute ta commande de tête
Un tartare saumon/avocat
Une salade Caesar sans croutons
Un croque-monsieur
Moi je pren...Vous notez pas?
Ah non pas besoin ! Continuez..
Moi je prendre le steak tartare et une grande bouteille de Chardonnays s'il vous plait
Ok !
Merci !
J'ai tout oublié !
On peut recommencer depuis le début?
Alors..des céréales?
J'sais pas si vous avez déjà croisé ce serveur
qui fait plein de blagues pas marrantes, tout le temps!?
Un peu comme moi.
On sait pas si le mec est serveur ou humoriste
En tout cas il est plus fort en tant que serveur, ça c'est sûr !
Donc le café, avec ou sans TASSE ! Haha !
Un steak bleu...mais bleu ciel ou bleu foncé? Haha
C'est combien un oeuf-mayo?
2000 euros ! Haha !
Non j'déconne !
5 euros !
Et je joue mon spectacle tous les vendredis soirs
à l'Hippopotamus pendant les happy hour, voilà !
Merci à tous!
"Philippe! Tu me mets l'addition sur la 8, s'il te plait !
Bonsoir!
Moi c'est Louis Siquet
Bon, sinon à part ça, j'ai rien contre les serveurs
J'les aime bien, même, vraiment !
J'crois plutôt que c'est eux qui m'aime pas
S'il vous plait !
Il est...parti...
D'ailleurs, ça m'empêche pas parfois
de laisser un petit pourboire, hein, aux serveurs
Ouais, chuis un mec comme ça, ouais !
Par contre,  quand, je fais ça, j'aime pas que personne le r'marque
J'aimerais que cet acte de générosité euh...
soit un peu remarqué !
quand même !
Oh regardez !
Il a laissé 2 euros de pourboire!
(applaudissements et cris de joie)
Merci monsieur !
Il me manquait juste 2 euros pour m'acheter un appartement
et mettre ma famille sous un toit !
Cet homme m'a sauvé la vie messieurs, dames!
C'est rien, c'est rien, c'est 2 euros, hein !
En tout cas, je dédicace cette vidéo à tous les serveurs et serveuses du monde
qui font un métier, faut le rappeler, pas toujours facile
Donc restez les mêmes, on vous kiffe comme ça !
Et puis la prochaine fois qu'on se croise au restau, ben ne crachez pas dans mon assiette
SVP
Bon, là je vous cache pas qu'on est bientôt 9 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne Youtube
Merci beaucoup !
Si on passe le cap des 9 millions avant ma prochaine vidéo
Vous savez quoi?
Eh ben j'organise un p'tit restau et je vous invite tous !
Et vraiment je le fais, hein !
Ça risque d'être...folklorique !
Bonjour !
Bonjour!
On est hum...9 millions !
Alors 400 000 burgers,
et pour les boissons?
(compte)
Vous notez pas?
Non, non, je ... continuez !
Grâce à la nouvelle mise à jour Youtube,
quand vous cliquez içi, là, sur ce bouton
Depuis un téléphone ou un ordi
ben, ça fait un truc nouveau
Allez-y, essayez, cliquez...
avec votre doigt ou votre souris...
Voilà...
Pas mal non? Plutôt cool!
Hyper simple pour s'abonner, plus instinctif
donc merci Monsieur Youtube
et puis merci à vous. Je vous aime énormément !
(chuchote) Lâchez un p'tit pouce en l'air svp, au revoir !